voici une autre chance en toute nouvelle
que je vais avoir la joie de chanter ce
soir pour la première par pékin pour
titre le jardin extraordinaire
il se passe de tout la glace
c'est un jardin extraordinaire
il ya les canards parle dans l'ain leur
donne du pain cuit leur terrière en me
disant 5 wehrli match monsieur trenet on
l'y voit aussi des statues qui se
tiennent tranquilles
le jour dit on mais moi je sais dès la
nuit venue elles s'en vont danser sur le
gazon a passé de la raab extraordinaire
il y a des oiseaux qui tiennent pas plus
près il compte du coeur d'un des petits
morceaux de gruyère comme clients il
nous sommes monsieur le maire et le
sous-préfet
il fallait bien trouver dans cette
grande ville maussade les touristes
s'ennuie au fond de leur autocar allait
bien trouvé
un lieu pour la promenade j'avoue que ce
samedi là je suis entré par hasard
extraordinaire
loin des noirs building c'est dépasse at
il ajouté y'avait teint pâle et donner
des primes au vert dans un coin de
verdure des petites grenouilles chanter
une chanson aux chandelles à lui
d'exercice paru tout rose d'émotion
elles sont honnêtes se croit la valse
brune une vieille chouette midi que le
distinguent avant leur extraordinaire
jeunesse ou d'un passé la plus belle des
filles elle vint prête moi et l'âme 10
ans manière vous me plaisait beaucoup
j'aime les gens dont les vieux bruit
pour vous il fallait bien trouver dans
cette grande ville perverse une gentille
amour est un petit flirt demain tant
qu'ils me fassent oublier que l'amour
est un commerce dans les bars de la cité
oui mais oui mais pardon
extraordinaire annonce du blizzard un
agent nous dit étendez vous sur la verte
bruyère je voudrais du luth pendant que
vous serez réunit sept agents
c'était un grand arrêt mais nous
préférions arthémy l'a27 d'une mouche
est secrète qu'elle fit découvrir pendu
voix pour ce coup là bas vous hard
assets
il est envoyé au coeur de ma chanson j
vol paroisse quand un chagrin mais
prompt il suffit pour ça un peu
d'imagination
il suffit pour ça d'un peu d'imagination
bal de nuit les oiseaux des fleurs
émerveillé artémise aux douceurs extase
de l'amour je vous retrouverai ce soir
la veillée
l appareil au premier jour je vous
aimerai sous la clarté lunaire du jardin
extraordinaire